The next step is to write the loop that's going to do
the crawling. And we said the process we want to follow is
to keep going as long as there are more pages to
crawl. We can do that with a while loop, and we
can use tocrawl like this in our test condition. If a
list is empty that's interpreted as false. If the list is
not empty, that would be interpreted as true. So this means
the same thing as testing if the length of the list
is zero, it's a cleaner way to write this by
just doing while tocrawl. Inside the loop, well, we want to
pick a page to crawl. We'll store that in the
variable page. And I'll leave it as a quiz for you
to figure out a way to pick the page to
crawl. There's certainly lots of different ways to do this. If
you're clever and can think about using all the things that
we learned about, you'll be able to have one line that
both initializes page to the next page we want to
crawl, and removes that page from the tocrawl list.